ja wir müssen auch über ein Video
sprechen das gerade du im Internet
kursiert das authentisch sein soll es
zeigt offenbar die Rekrutierung von ganz
jungen russischen Soldaten von
heftlingen das ist ein Video dort
offenbar von dem Gefängnishof und wer
dort in der Mitte steht das ist kein
geringerer als der Putin vertraute
prigoshi der der Chef dieser
Söldnertruppe Wagner und er wird dort
offenbar Häftlinge an für den Ukraine
Krieg was weißt du über die Echtheit
dieses Videos und wie ernst ist das zu
nehmen
das was wir hören aus unseren Quellen
ist dass dieses Video echt sein soll
tatsächlich gab es ja immer wieder
Berichte darüber dass
das gefangene dort rekrutiert werden
aber so ein Video das ist tatsächlich
neu es zeigt auf eine bedrückende Weise
wie verzweifelt Russland mittlerweile
ist was Rekrutierung angeht denn die
russischen Soldaten die Russen insgesamt
merken wie viele Opfer esse gibt auch
auf ihrer Seite natürlich auch auf der
ukrainischen das muss man dazu sagen
aber viele Russen sterben viele Russen
kehren verletzt zurück zehntausende
sollen tot sein und es scheint nicht so
dass ist funktioniert wirklich weitere
tausende zehntausende schnell zu
rekrutieren die Putin eigentlich
dringend bräuchte wenn er denn seine
Kriegsziele hier erreichen will
aus der Ukraine vielen herzlichen Dank
für deine Informationen Paul
[Musik]